いや あの 今日のところは百八十六ページのルーパサムッダーナというところで
色の起こり方 で あの まあそこら辺はいくらかまあ簡単に理解しておけばいいし
ちょっと明確に理解しようとすれば
ちょっとあの複雑になってしまうんです
まだ心の方が勉強してないんですから
で とにかくこの物質の世界
我々の人間の体と一緒に
全ての物質の世界はまとめて色だと言っていて
それは四つの基本的なエネルギーで出来上がっているんだと
その基本的なエネルギーはまとめたところで
またまた四つ必然的につなげてくるんだと
それはまあ基本的な八つとなってるんですね
物質の基本的な八つ いわゆるパーリ語で言えばパティヴィヤ
ポテジョ ワーヨ アンナカンダラ
ソウジャ 日本語になると
まあ何でしたっけ？地水火風と色と香りと滋養素と
じゃなくて 味と滋養素と四つですね
それで八つになるんですね
そこでこの基本的な物質の一番基本的なユニットはその八つでまとめているんですね
で 普通の人間は知ってる物質の世界
どれほど細かく考えたっても
大体その八つのセットから始まるだろうと思えるんです
で それからこの物質はなぜ生まれますかということは
これは最初からあったものか
あるいはいきなり現れたものかどうか
普通の人間は考えるかもしれませんだけど
仏教ではこういう最初ということは考えないんですね
物事には一番その基本はある
何て言いますか もう一番初めにという
こういうふうなところで現れたということは考えてないんです
それはあまり考えちゃったら
その前どうなったかと聞かなくちゃいけない
そうすると終わりがなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから まあそれ終わりがないということで言ってるんですね
今物質があるということは
前は他のものあったことは
それ前の他のものあったということ
もっと前も何かあったことであって
ですからものには始まりと終わりということはあまり考えてない
それは因果法則で一つのサイクルと捉めているんです
そこで我々はただそういうことではなくて
原因ある我々の物質的なものはどうやって現れますかということを考えるんです
そこで原因は四つ考えているんですね
その原因四つはこの パーリ語の言葉四つを覚えておいてください
カンマ チッタ ウトゥ アハara
という四つの原因から物質が生まれるんだと
で 物質といったっても
無常というものは忘れてないんですから
常に全てのものは猛烈な速さで消えていくんですね
物事は 物質は 消えていくんだけど
また生まれるんです だからものはある日突然消えてしまったということはないんです
何か消えてしまっちゃったら
その代わりに何かが生まれているんです
で そういうことで じゃあ生まれた現象がどうせ消えなくちゃいけないんですね
なぜならば 生まれた原因には何か生み出しちゃったら
その生み出したものに永遠にそのままあるようにしてあげることはできないんです
で それは因果法則で考えられるもので
人間は大体何か作ったら
すごく長持ちしてほしいという気持ちはたまにはあるんですけど
でもそれはなかなかできないし
で どうせ何か作ろうとする
その何か作ろうとすると
何か物事を持ってそれを作らなくちゃいけない
そのそのものを作るために使うものも消えるものなんですね
そう 消えなきゃ新しいものは作られませんだから
例えば いくらかの材料を持ってきて
新しい何か作ろうとすると
その持ってきた材料は変化しないものであるならば
他のものと統合したり
何かにそれなりの変化したりしなかったら
新しいものは作ることはできないんですね
ですから 材料になったものはどうせ変化するんですね
変化して新しいものはできちゃうんです
そう できたものは永遠にありますよというと
それおかしいんです なぜならば
それを作った原因も変化したものと変化
するものですから 変化するものに作られるものも変化しちゃうんですね
ですから それまた変化して違うものに変えてしまう
ですから その変化の流れはもうそれは絶対的で
もう変わることはないんです
そういうことで この今
私たちの私たちが世界を見ると物質があるんです
その物質は まあ私たちに見える物質は物質ではないんだけど
感じている物質 まあ一応物質とエネルギーがありまして
それはずっと変化していく
変化しているということは
あるものは消えて 新しいものが生まれる
その生まれる場合は この 4つの原因で新しい物質が生まれつつあるんだということなんです
そこで この 4つの原因も
よくよく考えると物質かもしれません
考えなくたっても物質から物質が生まれるし
でもちょっとこちらはちょっと違うところは
1番目はカンマという原因があるんだと
カンマっていうのは 仏教でよく使っているヒンドゥー教でもよく考えている業なんですね
で カンマという言葉をなぜ使うかというと
ちょっと特別な働きということで
仏教ではただ何か行為があったら
その行為にまた結果があるという
ごく普通な自然の意味でのカンマという言葉を使っているんです
で 行為に結果があるんだと
それは別に不思議なことでもなんでもないんだと
で そういうカンマもあります
で こちらでカンマと考えているのは
まあそれよりはこの心に
溜まるエネルギーなんですね
で それ我々はいつでも持っているエネルギーで
心に何かやったら 何かしたら
その まず何かしたくなるところ
何か心の中で何かこのちょっと不安定なエネルギーがあるんですね
その不安定なエネルギーがあるんだから
何かしてしまっちゃう
したところで また新しいエネルギーがそこで生まれてしまっちゃう
それでまた他のことをやらなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
それでまあずっと続けてしまっちゃうんですね
カルマはとにかく心の中に心のエネルギーではなくて
心にある一つのエネルギーなんですね
それ意味でなんでカルマと呼ぶんですかというと
私たちにはそれほどコントロールできないんです
心だったらいくらかコントロールできるんです
カルマとしてのエネルギーには
それほどコントロールはできないんです
で ですから あまり自我意識も
自我意識というか あまり意識もないんですね
これはカルマだという認識はなかなかできない
そういう特色があるんですね
だから誰でもカルマ 業っていうのは全然わからないと言うんだけど
何か教えてください わからないのは当たり前だって教えてあげたってわからないんですから
そういうことなんですね
カルマの働きっていうのは
じゃあ信じますかと それだったら別に信じなく
いくらか自分の生き方を計算してみると
なんか自分がなんか本能的にいろんなことをやってるでしょ
いいことであろうと悪いことあろうが
本人に聞いてもあまりわからない
ただまあやってしまっちゃうと
いわゆる性格とかね 特にこの我々の性格を構成しているのはもうほとんどカルマなんですね
生まれる時でも もう人格をもういくらかまあ設定されているんですね
その人にあなたの性格を変えてくださいと
そんなこと言ったっても
そんなできるわけじゃないんですね
ですから 本人に聞いても
なんであなたはそういう性格ですかと
なんで短気ですかと聞いたっても
ああ 私はこういうこういうわけで
もう短気性格ですよというということはありえない話なんですね
例えば 本人が自分の性格が悪いとわかっても
悪いということはわかってるんだけど
じゃあどういうわけで悪い性格になってるんですか？これはわからないんです
そこはその分がカルマであって
あるいは社会の影響で
親の影響で 学校の影響で
自分がこうなったよと言ったならば
ちょっと理由があるんですね
そうすると変化できるんですね
その性格が 悪い仲間に入っていたんだから悪い性格になったと
それである時間 他の仲間と付き合っていると
その性格は変えます ですから
我々に意識できる性格は変化できますけど
意識ができなくて もう生まれつきついてるという感じの性格などっていうのは
そういうエネルギーはカルマと言ってもいいし
この前もカルマについてまた違う定義をした覚えがありますからね
まあまあ その時その時
いろいろな角度でカルマのことを解釈しますから
全部まとめて覚えてください
じゃあアビダンマからはもう簡単にもう物事を考えますから
カルマっていうのは何か意志で何か我々はする
自分の意志で何かしたら
このしたことによって
このしたということのエネルギーですね
で ポテンシャルとして蓄積される
だからただのポテンシャルだから
別にもう感じるはずがないんですね
ですから この心にこの可能性みたいなポテンシャルなものがありまして
それはカルマで それはいろんなことを我々がやっていると
毎瞬間瞬間生まれるんですね
入るんですね カルマのポテンシャルが
ですから まあそれはまあ
じゃあ私はカルマをしないで業を起こさないでしましょうと思っても
それは完全に無理なことで
何かしたいという この何かやらなくちゃいけないという
この鬱々とした状態が消えない限りは
あのカルマは消えないんです
いつでもカルマは作りつつ作りっぱなしなんです
で じゃあ何もしたくないという
この状態に心がなりますかというと
まあそれはまた別の話で
で それができるのはもう完全に煩悩をなくして悟った時だけだそうですね
で 悟ったということは
煩悩が消えるということ
煩悩消えるということは
何かやりたいという気持ちはもう完全に消えるということなんですね
ですから それは次元が違う
ものすごい次元が違う
私たちは 例えばやる気が消えちゃったと
もう活発的にいたんだけど
もう全部もう消えちゃって
もう暗くなっちゃって
もう極力薄状態になったと
じゃあその人はカルマはしないだろうと
そんなことじゃないんです
それは極力の煩悩なんですね
ただ煩悩はものすごい恐ろしく固まっただけ
ですから その人もただ怠けている
何もしないということで生きているんですね
ですから すごいカルマを作っているんですね
ですから 普通の世界でやる気が消えたということは
カルマのエネルギーもどんどんもう新しいカルマを作れなくなったということではなくて
どうせ同じパターンでずっとカルマは作りっぱなしなんです
それはもう止められない
そうじゃなくて この物事の無常をちゃんと理解して
物事に執着する心はどんどん消えていくと
別に何かやらなくちゃいけないという
この我々の心の不満な状態は消えてしまったと
だから心に何も不満がない
心は満足状態になったと
いわゆる完全に満足状態になったということは
それは停止状態なの ストップ状態なんですね
もう動かない状態 ですから
その悟った人のやる気がない状態というのは
ものすごい高いレベル
高いの超越した状態で
普通の我々が考えているこのやる気が消えちゃった状態じゃないんです
やる気が消えちゃったということは
やっぱりものすごい不善心が生まれた
生まれたということなんですね
人間というのはこの善心
いい心が生まれるとかなり働くんです
すごい行動的になるんです
それは心の法を説明すると説明しますので
すごい行動的で明るくて
もう軽く動き回るんです
くよくよはしない 自分の行動をストップはしない
ずっと何かやって その時その時やって明るくなるんですね
ですから このうつとか
このやる気が消える状態っていうのは
そういう戦心が消えていって
消えていって暗くなって暗くなって
怒りやら不満やら いろんなものが溜まって溜まって
もう煩悩という悪い煩悩
いわゆる不善なる心相がものすごく強烈になったということですね
ですから 動けなくなっちゃっただけ
ですから それは大変な悪い状態です
それとあの このサダタイ等の何もしない状態とはものすごい違います
正反対です じゃあとにかくカルマというエネルギーがありまして
ポテンシャルがありまして
それはどうせ心の問題なんです
心にあるんです 心にあるんだから
我々知らないんだけど
それから物質が生まれるんだと
で あの それ大変考えてほしいことなんです
で カルマは物質ではありません
ただのポテンシャルだけであって
それで認識もできない
これということ で 物質が生まれる
だからカルマから生まれるんだから
もうどうしようもないことなんです
で じゃあ私たちにとってわかりやすく説明すると
あの もっとすごい俗的なカルマ論をとって
例えば人が あの よく日本でもよく人を脅すために脅かすために言ってる話でしょう
じゃああなたの体はもうすごい病弱ですと
それはあんた過去生で
まあいろいろ殺人なんか起こしたんではない
起こしたんだと ですから
あんた今病弱ですよという話があるんですね
そういう じゃあ例を考えてみましょう
もしその話が本当であるならば
で その人の体が弱い 何食べても生まれる物質は弱い
どんな運動しだっても
比較的に他の人とは弱い
すぐ病気になる そういう人々がいくらでもいるんですね
で じゃあその人に自分の体の弱さを
この生まれつき持ってる弱さを何かすることはできるかというと
何もできない どれ 例えば一生懸命頑張っても
やっぱり他の健康的な人と比較的にこの弱さがずっとあるんですね
例えば生まれた時はもう足が弱くて歩けなくなったと
歩けない状態で生まれたんだと
みんな歩けない状態で生まれますけど
それはそういうことではなくて
不自由に生まれたんだと
そこで それでももう頑張って頑張って
いろいろリハビリやってやって歩けるようになったと
としても もう歩けるんだと
それでも健康的な体で生まれた人と比べると
比較的にすごい弱いんですね
その割り当てはもう変えないんですね
それはお金で計算して考えちゃうと
まあ例えば人が生まれて
自分の経済的な能力は
例えば貧しいところで生まれたんだと
貧しいところで生まれたんだけど
十円入ると大体まあ六円ぐらいまあ使って四円残るんだと
そこでその人はすごい豊かなところに連れて行って
豊かにしてしまっちゃうと
ものすごいお金入るようにしてあげちゃうんだと
そうしてあげても あの四
六と四の割り当ては変わらないんです
それは皆様自分の人生を考えてみてください
小さい時から今まで その収入と出費というんですか
その その割り当ては変わらない
で 自分で自害心が生まれてくると
いろいろ工夫していくらか変化できます
例えばもっと苦労して貯金の方が増やしちゃうとかはできますよ
あるいはまあ甘えてもっとお金使うとか
そういうことはできますけど
でもある日 まあ貯金の数字が上がっちゃうと何かが起こるんです
何かが起こっちゃって
ドーンとあのお金が消えちゃうんです
消えて 後でまあ五 六年頑張って貯金は増やしてみたんだけど
七年目で何かが起こってまたあれ減っちゃう
それで全部計算してみると
また同じくなってしまったんです
そういうのは だからこれは今お金のことで言ったんですね
知識のことも同じなんです
例えばどれぐらい努力すれば勉強よく身に付きますかね
その努力の量はもうずっと同じなんです
何の努力もしないで もうなんか遊びながらさっさと物を覚える人が
もう死ぬまでもうどんな勉強であっても
どんな難しいことだったでも遊びながらやってしまっちゃう
かなり勉強して勉強して
かなりもう本読んで読んで
ありとあらゆることを探して探して
もう苦労して勉強する人は死ぬまで同じ
いくら博士になろうと
いくら大有名な教授になろうが
勉強に苦労したならば
その時でも同じ苦労するんです
だから人を見ると それはもうよく見えることなんです
その 何と言いますか この割り当てというか
そのプロポーションだけはもうどうしようもないんです
で それはまあカルマなんですね
バカな質問を一つさせてください
瞑想に関してはいかがですか
同じです それもちょっと今言おうと思って
ちょっと忘れかけてたんで
その同じこと この瞑想についても同じことなんです
普通の人生で自分が何かやろうとすると
結構苦労する人であるならば
もう覚悟を決めた方がいいんです
瞑想についても それをその分苦労しないと
その結果が得られないんです
そこで何かパッとひらめ
分かったということもありますね
人間にはいつでもあることで
このひらめきということ
常に そこでもう結構教えて説明して
説明して あげてあげて
それでもわからない それまたまた教えると
もう分かったと 別に頭悪いわけじゃなくて
この あ 分かったという
このひらめきは遅い人がいるんですね
その人々について瞑想も同じことなんですね
その まあまあちゃんと人格
あのアビダルマも出てくるんです
この人の性格 人格もきめ細かく分別しているテキストがございまして
まあそちらではそういう話は結構あります
まあそういうのはカルマだと
なかなかカルマっていうのは理解しにくいもので
だからまあ説明した私の説明を聞いて
ああ そんなもんだろうとぐらいでいいんです
この世の中の人はどうどうと言ってるカルマ論はもう何のことなく捨てた方がいいんです
別に完璧に嘘言ってるわけじゃないんだけど
真実をいつも言ってるわけでもないんです
そんなに明確にわかるわけじゃないんです
いろいろ超能力者なんか出てきて
あんたは過去世でこんなことをやって
だから今今世でこうなってるよと
そんなのは言えません
これすっごい計算難しいことなんです
ものすごく難しいことなんです
ですから この 一応大雑把に
まあこんなもんだろうと
自分の人生をちょっと考えると
なんとなくパターン決まってるということは分かってしまうでしょう
で そのパターンなんですね
だからといって それは徹底的に固定しているとかというと
自分の努力次第にいくらか変化することはできます
例えばお金がなかなか入らない人がいて
もう 100円入っちゃうと
もう 101円逃げてしまっちゃうんだと
で それでその人はずっと努力するんだと
努力して 100円入るところではなくて
1,000万円ぐらい入るぐらいになるんだと
そうすると その人はどうしても経済状態はすごい豊かでしょ
そういう風に豊かにはなりますけど
1,000万入ると やっぱりその場合は 100万円はもう 1,200万円が飛んでいっちゃうんです
でもレベルは高いんですね
で 私はこの知ってるいろんな人々いて
このものすごい理解 何か理解するのはもう抜群に瞬時に理解できる
すごいそういう能力あった人々
昔見ていたんですね で
なんか言おうとすると
すぐまあそういうことはもうわかってるんです
そういうなんですけど
僕は今頭に浮かんでいる人々っていうのは
まあそういう理解は早い
鋭く早いんだけど いろいろ訳があって
家庭のいろんな問題があったりして
学校に行ってないんですね
やっと義務教育なんとか終わっただけで
それでもう何かして生活しちゃう
だから何もわからない
で そこで僕はあまり たまにもったいないなとも思う時もあるんで
こういう人々はもしずっと勉強して行ったならば
何も苦労なしにどれほどうまくいくでしょうと
で だからカルマから割り当てられてる部分はあるんだけど
自分がそれは使えなかったんです
他の原因があって 知識はもういわゆる理解力は鋭く鋭いんだけど
いろんなこの経済的な豊かさの分がもう低いし
それで自分せっかく持っていたいいカルマは結果は出せなくなってるんですね
出せなくなってるんだけど
自分の割り当てだけは働いてはいるんです
そこでね もの そういう風に逆にものすごい鈍感な人が僕を見ているんですね
人は鈍感ですけど 結構豊かな家族で生まれちゃって
そこにいくらでもお金払って
ありとあらゆる塾 塾 歩き回ったりして
まあいろいろ工夫したり
うちにまでもう個人的な指導を受けてもらったりして
もう大学まで行ってしまった
大学も卒業と そこで大学を卒業した後
偉くなっちゃいますけど
生まれつき鈍感だからかなり苦労しているんですね
片っ端から塾に行ってる人
うちにも先生呼んでもらって勉強してしてして
ですから 本人の苦労はそのままなんですね
理解するためにはかなり努力しなさいと
苦労しなさいと それは消えてない
そこでなんで大学まで卒業できたかというと
知識としては鈍感なカルマ付いてるんだけど
まあ他のところで恵まれているんですね
そういうのは総合的に計算したところで
その人のカルマなんですね
だからあんた過去世でこうやったんだから
こうです ああやったんだから
あれですって そんな簡単には言えない
その付いたカルマの効率性も
またこの心のその カルマをした時の心のエネルギーによってまた左右されるんです
かなり複雑な法則なんです
どれほど複雑かというと
釈迦様はそんなことをあなた方は考えるな
釈迦様も別に人の考えること考える自由も禁じているわけじゃないんだけど
カルマについてはもう考えない方がいいんだ
人間に考えて理解できるものじゃないんだ
勝手に考えようと思っちゃったら狂ってしまうだけですよと
結果としては あんたは頭はおかしくなりますよ
全然把握できないから
ということだから まあ大雑把な理解で十分ではないかなと
またかえって どうしても我々の管理外のものだから放っておけばいいんです
過去のカルマは管理外のことだから
その代わりにお釈迦様が言うのは頑張りなさいと
いつでも カルマは良ければ悪ければそれに関係なく
努力すると努力の結果が得られますから
もうカルマっていうのは無視することはできるんです
まあカルマ論を喋る日ではないんですから
そこら辺で止まって カルマから物質が生まれてくるということだけ
ということは 我々の体っていうのは
ただ単に簡単に親からもらった体ですよ
ああだこうだとか言ったっても
そうでもないんですね
この原因四つですから
例えば分かりませんだけど
僕もはっきりとは  四つの原因で色が体が生まれるならば
四分の一なんですね カルマは
ですから 私の体の構造の四分の一
構造を決める場合は四分の一責任を持っているのはカルマなんですね
そういうことで 人の体は体からでもわかるんです
健康って適当かね 大変抵抗力あるとか
いろんな体もあるし 生まれつき心臓が悪い人もいるし
血管が悪い人がいるし
神経の働きが悪い人です
まあいろいろですよ そこで体はがっちりしているんだけど
見た目は良くないかという人もいるし
体はすごい弱くて  大変まあそういう状態なんですけど
見てすごいかっこいいなと
そういう感じする感じする人もいるし
だからそこら辺は親にはどうすることもできないんです
本人にもできない 例えば
どんな服を着てもぴったしすぐ姿勢に決まってしまう人がいるでしょ
どんなもうだらしのないものでも
もうすぐ自分の体に作っちゃったら
まあもうすぐぴったし合うと
いろんな専門家を頼んで
まあ一生懸命おしゃれしてて
もう服に隠れている人もいるし
そこら辺はどんな苦労したってしょうがないんです
とにかく我々の体の一部はカルマから作ってくる
そこでこれがポイントは
じゃあカルマから体の一部ですから
心臓だけですか？腎臓だけですか？とか
そうじゃないんです 我々そういう部分を見てないんです
体とエネルギーですから
全てなんです だから髪の毛一本一本でも物質ですから
そちらもカルマから生まれているんです
全て全体的に カルマでないものは一つもないんです
それがカルマ 二番目はチッタと読むんですね
チッタは心 で 心から物質は生まれるんだ
またこの心という時も
また自分のコントロールない世界なんですね
我々知っているのは心ではなくて心の現象なんですね
例えば人が怒ったと あの人怒ってるんだと
心がなければ怒らないんですね
心に生まれた怒りの心相を見て心を推測するしかないんです
あの人笑ってるんだと
あの人すごい楽しい もう楽しい
もう楽しんでるんだと
というと 心に楽しみの心象が生まれて
ですから まあそれは見えるんだけど
心そのものっていうのは
まあまた認識しない 認識不可能なものなんですね
心の現象しか理解できない
まあそれにまあ難しい理論ありますけどね
まあ我々何か認識するのは変化を認識するんですね
変化しなきゃ認識しなくなっちゃうんです
ですから この例えば同じ音をじっと聞いてると聞こえなくなっちゃうんですね
同じ味をずっと味わってると
その味がわからなくなっちゃうんです
変化しなきゃいけないんです
ですから 心も変化すると違う心なんです
だから心に怒りやら欲やら嫉妬
それから慈悲とか いろいろ感情が生まれると
心の 心というものがあるんじゃないかなと感じてしまう
悩んだり 楽しがったり
いろいろありとあらゆる様々な感情で心変化する
変化することによって
心というものがあるだろうとわかる
わかるんです 結局 その時でもはっきりとわかっているのは
心に生まれる感情であって
怒りとか嫉妬とか そういう感情であって
心そのものではない 心そのものっていうのは
まあほとんど同じもので
まあ同じ現象で変化していくんですね
瞑想の世界から考えたっても
まあこれは心だという風にわかったケースはないんです
心は強いと そういう風にも理解できるんですね
心はもう今すごいエネルギーは多いと
今エネルギーはないんだと
うん まあそれはそれで置いておいて
まあ一応心というものが
まあ心という働きがございまして
それから我々の体はまあ作られているんです
物質的なものは心から作られている
まあそれは例えば生きているという言葉に入れ替えると
我々は生きてるんだから
やっぱり体も生きてる間はそのまま
そのままではなくて変化しながら続いてしまっちゃうんです
もし私たちが死んじゃったら
この体は成長することはそこでない
その代わりに物質として腐ってしまっちゃうだけ
体は物質として腐ってしまわないで
とにかく変化しながら生き続けて
その場合はこの心からいっぱい物質が生まれてくる
それで心から生まれる物質の体全体なんです
体全体のエネルギー 心から生まれてくる
じゃあ今原因 2つ言いました
その 2つも心の世界 カルマとチッタは心の世界
そこで物質はどこから生まれるんですか？と聞くと
半分は心から生まれてるんですね
じゃあ何か信じがたいみたいな話なんですね
じゃあ物質の世界 地球がありまして
宇宙のありとあらゆる物質
我々知ってる物質 もう限りない物質の世界あるんじゃないんですか？どうやって半分心から生まれるという
それが で そういう質問に答え二つ言えるんですね
一つは 全ての物質的な存在の半分は心から生まれてくるんだというならば
我々は認識していない生命体いっぱいあるんじゃないか
あるいは地球もそのまま命として生きれるんじゃないかなと
地球はただの物体ではなくて
もしかすると巨大な生命
大きさとしてすごい巨大な生命エネルギーではないかというふうにも考えられる
そうするとそちらに物質があるというふうに考えられること
もう一つは アビダンマで我々仏教で気になっているのは生命の説明だから
別に物質に云々という必要はないんだから
自分の体のことだから
生命には身体がありますから
そうすると生命ついている物体の場合は身体ですし
その身体のケースでは半分は心から生まれているんだと
宇宙のことは別に関係ないんだと
生命体ではないんだからというふうに言えるんです
例えば時計なんかはもう生命体ではないんだから
時計の物質は半分心から作ってるよという必要はないんだと
なぜならばそれはもう正真正銘の物体ですよ
では 私の体の場合は半分心から生まれてるんだと
なぜならば生命体だからというふうな解釈もできる
解釈は二つ 一つは全ては生命体で見るか
一部を生命体で見るかということなんです
時計は生命の延長として見てる
人間の使う道具 そういうふうに解釈する
それは時計だけ考えちゃうとね
まあこうなりますけど
まあまあ ちょっとその前に問題解決しておかないと
時計とか人間作る道具っていうのは
まあちょっと置いておいて
それはそんなに問題にはならないんですね
それよりはこの じゃあ宇宙全体
すべての我々人間認識しているこの宇宙ありますね
まあ認識はしてないんだけど
推測だけでやってますけどね
で その宇宙の宇宙全体
すべて生命体で見るか
あるいは宇宙にいる一部だけ生命体で見るかということなんです
宇宙全体的に生命体で見るならば
まあそのどんな物質であろうが
半分は心から生まれてるんだと言えるんです
宇宙という存在のほんの微かな一部だけ生命体というならば
まあその一部の生命体の半分は物質から生まれてくるんだ
心から生まれてくるんだと言えるんです
だからどっちにしますかね
で そう言ったっても分かりませんだからね
だいたいもうあの釈迦尊の拠点
釈迦尊にはそういう話はできなかったと思いますね
なぜできなかったのは
まあそのお釈迦様が生きていたこの社会背景では
そこまで質問は いわゆる我々
この現代科学的に作っている概念が発展してなかったんです
私は今 現代的な概念を使って喋ってますから
そういうくだらない質問も出てくるんです
でも 昔もその質問は考えたんです
存在は心ですか あるいは物質ですかというような
でお釈迦様にはなかなか説明できる環境ではなかったんですね
で でもお釈迦様っていうのは言っておかなくちゃいけないものは何とか工夫して言ってはおくんです
理解するするかしないかに関係なく
何とかの形で言ってはおいておくんです
そこは残ってるんです
で こういう話があるんです
話ではないんです これは 三月二日のテキストに
あのかなりのいくらかの経をたくさんまとめてあるところであるんで
あの すっごいこの原始的というか
まあおかしいよ 誰でもあの経読んじゃったら
このすごいおかしいやと思うほどの経なんです
たくさんあるんだから
また困っちゃうんですね
たった一個だけ迷子になってるならば
それをポイと捨てちゃえばいいんだから
そうじゃないんです かなりの量があるんです
読んだらおかしいんです
こういうある人はこう質問するんです
なんで 時々雨が降るんですか
お釈迦様の答えはね アッティワッサワラハカーナデーヴァ
雨を降らせるという名前の神がいるんだと
その神が まあ神 神でもいいしね
時々我々の まあ本来の力で遊ぼうでは
楽しもうではないかと
本来持ってる力で楽しもうではないかと
自分たちが思うんだと
それで自分たちが自分本来持ってる力を出しますと
その時は雨が降ります
そういう風なもう今日たくさん
これ一つの例だけで またいろんな現象について
なんで雲が曇ってるんですか？とかね
なんで白い雲があるんですか？と
なんで雲が黒くなってるんですか？とか
で なんでものすごい熱い空気が
例えば夏ですか その時はすごい熱い空気が
風が吹いたり また冬になるとすごい冷たい風が吹いたり
そういう そういう質問をするたびに
もう何て言いますか 冷たい風に何て言いますか
日本語に 何か言葉あるでしょうと思いますけど
この冬なんかね まあ北風でしょ
ものすごい寒気ね こなし
こなし 例えばこなしっていう神がいるんだと
すごい簡単な説明で その神は時々自分たちのエネルギーを出そうではないかと思って行動するんだと
その時はすごい冷たい風を吹いてしまいます
そこで寒気もそういう説明なんですね
それ説明聞いたら 普通聞いたからおかしいと思うでしょ
雨が降るのも神の働きで
寒気になるのも神の働きでと
洪水になるのは神の働きで
そこで太陽も月も全部神なんです
星も全部 片っ端から で
仏教のこの神という概念はすごく怪しいんですけど
あの まあ自然にも神と言うし
雨に雨に神と言うんですか
何のことなく いわゆるサンスクリット語
パーリ語っていうのは同義語いっぱいありますから
一つのものに言葉いっぱいあります
その中で一つは雨 雨の神という言葉を使ってるんです
例えばパーリ語で あの雨が降りますということは
パーリ語で言うとデーヴォヴァッサと言わなくちゃいけないんです
デーヴァっていうのは神なんですね
神にもデーヴァって言うんです
雨が降りますというと
誰でもパーリ語を知っている人は
誰でもデーヴォヴァッサと書かなくちゃいけないんです
天国にいる神が見ていても同じデーヴォという言葉を使っているんです
だからそこはちょっとまあ曖昧というか
怪しい 怪しくなるところもその言葉の問題でもあります
それからあの光り輝く
という意味でもディッパティーティデーヴォ
なぜ神かというと もう輝いているんだからデーヴァと言うんですよというもので言葉使っているし
ですから輝くものにも神と言うんです
雨にも神 と呼んでます
神にも神と呼んでます
じゃあまあそこはまあ別なこの説明で
あの あの お経はどうやって見ればいいんですかね
で 地球は神なんです 女性なんです
ですから どう見てもいいんですかね
その場合は だからもしかするとこの
もしかするとじゃないんです
やっぱりそこで神と言ってるのは
我々知ってる生命とは違うということで
神といったらもう人間にはどうしても理解できない存在なんですね
神だから 我々考える時間空間関係では考えられないんであって
ですから そちら何かの生命というエネルギーがあって
そこから物質が生まれて
その自分の物質次元で自分の働きをしている
そうすると水も神になっちゃうんです
で それはその通りだと言えないのは
ヒンドゥー教ではもう雨も神で
水も神で 火も神でと もう何度も考えてきたんだから
その考え方とダブってしまっちゃうんですね
だからその考え方だったら別に仏教では認めてないし
そうじゃなくて違う次元で物質っていうのは心なしに存在しないという
物質には独立することはできないんだと
というならば また別 別な話で
だからいくらか言うと
この全ての我々知ってる我々に知ることは可能
知られる まあ知ってることはできる
物質的な世界においては
やっぱり心の働きがずっとあるようには考えてるんですね
その考え方を我々知ってるレベルにレベルダウンして考えると
やっぱりあの もうごく日本で日本でも言ってるように
もう山にも川にもどっちにでも石にでも
やっぱり もう 魂でも霊魂でも命でも何でもいいんですけど
命があるんだと というふうな
ところにレベルダウンして考えると
そういうことになっちゃうんですね
それはちょっと考えて
まあ別にまあ遊びに考えてください
で もう次のポイントなんですけど
どちらの方が量的に多いかと
物質と心があって じゃあ量的に多いのはどちらですかと言えば
どちらの方が多いと思いますか？心の方が多いんです
量的に見ると物質の量は少ないんです
心の量は多い だから当然心の量は多いんだから
そちらのパワーが大きいんですね
どちらがイニシアチブを取りますか？ いやいや
それは考えてない 絶対考えない
それはイニシアチブといったらどんな意味でイニシアチブ
どちらが先行して  ああ
先行する場合は心ですね
それで量的に考えると心の方が量が多い
なぜかというと それ私はなんかすごい邪教言ってるような
これお坊さんたちは言わない話なんですけど
で ほとんど誰も考えてないですから
私だけですかね 余計なこと考える
あの 存在の次元による場合は
全く物質と関係ない存在の次元もあるんですね
いわゆる純心だけの存在もありますから
物質 物質に密接してもう離すことは全く不可能な
体と心一体になってる生命の次元は大勢ありますけど
どんどんどんどん高い高いレベルに行ってみると
物質は関係なく心だけの次元が出ている
一番上のと そうすると一番下へ下へ行くと
我々は一応中ぐらいに考えると
人間には心も体も半分半分で関係があるようになってきて
下へ下へ行くと やっぱり心の働きが弱くなっちゃうでしょ
じゃあ動物でそういう
なんか物質みたいにいきなり動物いるんじゃないんで
例えばカニとか手なんか手というんですか
あれは取って食べても食べてまたカニ置いておけば
一年経つとまたあるんですね
何回アメリカどうかでテレビで見たんだけど
レストランでもうすごい大きなカニを
で まあ捕まって 足 この両手だけ取って
また戻しちゃう まあ一本だけで取るのは
それかなり大きいんですね
それでちゃんと料理して食べると
それでまた一年経つとまた伸びてあって
また捕まってある分だけ取って食べると
そういうことをやってますから
その次元になってくると
心よりはやっぱり物質の方が優勢になってるんですね
そういう低次元の生命になってくると
かなりそういう生命がいるんですね
これ生きるもの 例えば海の中にもありますでしょ
あの 全く植物 植物みたいにもうゆらゆらしてるんだけど
よく本当は生命 正真正銘の生き物でとか
それさらにさらに近い
近いレベルで見ると 心っていうのはほとんどわからないほど物質だけの次元が出てくるんです
ということで あの 昔から地獄はこの地下にありますと言ってるんだからね
地下は溶岩しかないんだけどね
だから今の人は笑っちゃうでしょ
そんな嘘ばっかしとかね
そんなに笑えないよ 溶岩のレベルで
次元でどうせ生命はあり得るんです
生命の存在 笑い話ではないです
なぜなら 僕は溶岩見たことはなかったし
この日本に来て初めてテレビだけでも本当に本物は見たいんだけど
なかなかそういう出るところには行かせてくれませんだから
なんかよろこ動画であるみたいで
行ってハワイに行ったって見えるみたいですけどね
やっぱり直接見たいっていうのはすごくあるんです
小さいガキの時から そのすごいそれ不可思議で
なんで地獄にあれほど熱くて生命はいるいるんでしょうかとと思っていたんだから
やっぱりテレビで溶岩見ると
なんとなく感じることはあるんですね
それであっちこちありますでしょ
昔 あの火山爆発して それから溶岩があっちこち
もうすごい今みんな見物ばっかりキレキレだと見るだけですけど
やっぱりすごい波動と雰囲気が違うんですね
あの石 石だけでってのもある
固まった溶岩で 普通の岩とかなんとか見て見ると出てくる感じとは違うんです
ですから この 心のエネルギーはないとは言えないんですね
我々を疑うのは私たちの心と似てる
同じだと思うんだから
その心は分かってないんだから
我々には怒りあったり
欲望があったり 楽しみがあったり
苦しみがあったりとかね
それはもう心の現象であって
それはそう全くない 基本的な
ただ生命というぐらいの基本的なエネルギーで考えなくちゃいけない
そうすると なんとなくまあ分かるでしょうと思います
で このあっちこっち微かに微かに
お釈迦様の言葉を残してあって
そういうところから僕はものすごくもう本当に微かしかないんで
それもなかなか見つからないんです
見失うんです で 読むと
で ほとんど経典読んでみなきゃまたわからない
読んでも見つからない
何回読んで見つからないような
この あるんです それはもう発掘するぐらいの
もう面白いと言えば面白いんだけどね
で やってくると いろんなものの発見が私にはありましたけどね
やっぱり心 先行して次に物質なんですね
とにかく そういうことをまたわかりやすくまとめますが
ということは 例えば全宇宙があって
物質的な宇宙があって
それであるならばそれぐらい巨大な心の働きもあると言えるんです
で 量的に心の方が多いんだから
それよりも心の方が多いんだと
じゃあそれからあの ちょっと違う話に戻ります
この宇宙の宇宙論に入りましたから
宇宙というのはもう人間には想像できない時間単位で
どんどんどんどん現れてきて
どんどん消えていっちゃうんですね
で 今は宇宙は膨張時代
だからこの膨張するもうギリギリまで膨張するんですね
それ以上は膨張不可能という物質物理法則では不可能なところまで膨張する
その時間は仏教では一つ単位で考えているんですね
膨張時代は 一光年と それで破壊するんですね
あまりにも膨張しすぎて物質は消えちゃう
膨張して膨張して 今はいくら膨張したっても
まあ素粒子やら原子やら見つかりますけど
それはさらにさらにさらに膨張すると
もう原子もなくなっちゃうんです
素粒子もなくなっちゃうんです
それでもう消えるんですね
じゃあ消えた瞬間にもう物質はありませんから
といえば空なんですね
それでその空状態はまた何て言いますか
コントラクション 収縮
収縮始めちゃうんですね
それで収縮 初めは何もないんだけど
収縮始めるとどんどん微かな物質の素粒子なんか生まれてきたりして
それでどんどんどんどんそれをまとめて大きいものが出てきて
またまとめて大きいものが出てきてとか
またあっちこっち固まったりして
いろんな宇宙の星団と言うんですか
このいろんなギャラクシーなんかそこを生まれてきたりして
またどんどんどんどんまあ生命体がまで出てくるわけですね
生命体の場合は物質構造すごい複雑でしょ
原子よりは 分子よりは
複雑ですから ですからそれはまあ吸収している過程でそうなっていく
それはさらにさらに吸収しちゃうとどうなるんですかね
ですから もうそれ以上吸収できないというところまで吸収しちゃう
それでバーンと爆発させなくちゃいけないんですね
爆発しちゃったら それからまた膨張を始める
それは仏教の宇宙論なんですね
それで爆発したところで
もう別に物があるわけじゃないんです
ただのエネルギーだけでね
それをどんどんどんどん適当なところで
あの 私たちはとにかく膨張する時代で生まれた人々
吸収する時代で こういうね
星やら生まれたら 我々の変化は逆なんです
今感じている変化はこの膨張時代の変化なんです
この体は膨張していくんです
原子とか そこでもしかするとあの世界では逆の変化かもしれません
それはそれ 理解できないでしょ
こういう例えで理解できるんですね
今は赤ちゃんが生まれて老人が死ぬでしょ
だから逆に考えると 老人が生まれて赤ちゃんが死ぬとか
そういう逆なんですね
そういう風に考えると分かりやすいと思います
別にその当時で老人が生まれて赤ちゃんが死ぬということになるかどうかは別なのかもしれません
わかりませんけどね とにかく逆の変化なんです
で そういう膨張時代 全部ビッグバンから膨張して消えるところまで 一光年と数えますから
仏教は そういう光年というのはもう何万
もう何百万とか 無数年とか数えちゃうんですね
だからまあまあ とんでもない時間論なんです
そういうわけで 仏教ではこのヨーロッパ的な神様という
あんなくだらない 何考えてるんですかと
は考えてない あんまりにも小さすぎてもう話にならない
そういう概念なんです
でもこの吸収する宇宙ではね
本当に 面白い変化でしょうね
どうかわからないんだけど
一応過程はまあ老人が生まれて赤ちゃんが死ぬような過程なんです
[背景音楽]今私たちには何も例えはない
ああいう風にこういう風にというもの
何一つこの世の中でないんです
すべてのものは膨張時代の物質だから
まあちょっと面白く言える何かあるかなと思ったんだけど
この世界ではそういう画期的なものはね
ないでしょう  そういう風にこの宇宙は現れたり消えたり
現れたり消えたりする
そこで それは物質の波でしょ
物質の波がそういう風になっているならば
その物質よりそれを支えている
物質から切り離せること何にもできない心というエネルギーがあるんです
ですから この そこら辺まで他の宗教で考えてないんだけど
そこら辺も神だと誤解する可能性あるんです
言い過ぎかどうか分かりませんだけど
こういう話あまりはしないんですけど
まあ大体こういう話は
まあまだいくらでも喋れますけど
まあ人間の脳細胞の領域とはもうちょっと
外れているところですから
どこか辺自分が自分のコントロールしないと
まあ仏教の言ってる話に戻ります
で あの 仏教で面白い話がありまして
で ある日この地球はもう全部消えちゃうんだと
で 仏教でよく考えているのは
今度は火で消えるんです
火の元素 この地水火風のこの割り当てがね
どんどん変化しちゃう
今度はこの火の元素が大きくなっちゃう
火の元素が大きくなっちゃったら
もう全部燃えて消えちゃう
だから一つの現象が余計に大きくなっちゃったら
もうバラバラになるんだから
お互いのちゃんと今ちゃんとお互いに地水火風がちゃんとぴったしと合ってるんだから
ちょっと地が大きいか風が大きいか
それぐらいのことで これあんまりにも一つの現象大きくなっちゃうと
4つもなければ存在しないんだから
もう物質的な存在は消えちゃう
そこで火が大きくなってくるとどうなるかというと
まず我々にわかる現象は燃えることなんです
そこでこの太陽もこのもう今一人で頑張ってますけど
爆発するんだ そして 2つになっちゃうんです
2つになっちゃったらお互いに離れちゃうでしょ
離れて まあ昔風に考えると
今我々に見えるように考えると
地球はこうやって太陽が回ってくるんだから
こう両方こうやって回っちゃうようになっちゃうんです
いわゆる太陽が爆発 太陽がこうやって離れちゃうし
地球はどんな方向を見てもそこに太陽があるとということになっちゃうんです
まあその時は人間はもういないんだから
けど やっぱり お釈迦様は昔の人に分かりやすくね
まあ東から太陽が出て
もうちゃんと西から沈んだところで
また東から太陽が昇る
ですから昼しか昼だけやっても夜がなくなって
そうするとあまりにも暑くて
全部川やらもう全部どんどんどんどんもう消えていっちゃう
まあ最初には海も全部消えちゃう
それでいろんな火事があったりして
全部まあまあわかりやすくこう言うんですね
今のこの海はものすごい大きくて
もうヒマラヤの山を入れちゃっても
もうどーんと中に入るぐらいすごい深いんだけど
ある日は人のかかとぐらいになっちゃうんだと
水の量は でもそれはこの例えで
当時の人々の理解できるように言ってることで
具体的に考えるとそうはならないんですね
なぜかというと その時に人間いるわけじゃないでしょうに
そこでどうせ塩だからもう固まってしまうんですね
そこまで水が減るということはないんだから
で それはまあ別に とにかく基本的なことは
まあ太陽とかそんなものは全部爆発したりして
地球爆発したりして まあ燃えて消えるんだ
じゃあすべて燃えて消えると人間が
生命はどうなるんですか？生命には 2つしか決めることはない
そこで この物質的な この燃やしている
この火だけ優先になっている
この次元に関係ない もうちょっと上の物質的に関係ない次元に生命が行ってしまって
それは梵天なんです 梵天のランクいっぱいあるんです
そこで火の幻想で やられない次元があって
そこで生まれるんだと
みんな何の瞑想しなくたって
儲かっちゃうんです で
それには瞑想いらないんですね
今 梵天に生まれ変われたければ
すっごいきつい瞑想しなくちゃいけない
その地球破壊の時の梵天に生まれるためには必要じゃない
なぜかというと どうせ生命は転生しなくちゃいけないでしょうし
もう転生する場所がないんです
そういうことで 例えば大学に学生は 300人必要ですよ
でも願書を出しているのは 200人だったら
なんのことなく試験もなしにみんな入れてくれるでしょ
そんな感じです で 試験なしに
もう梵天に生まれる でもそういう面白い話だけではなくて
これで火の幻想でも燃え盛ってますから
それで生命にはいることはできない
それで下の地下の次元もありますよ
ものすごい恐ろしい次元
火でも焼けないぐらいの物質の次元があるんだから
上へ行くか下へ行くか
どっちかに最後には生命決めなくちゃいけない
そこでかすかにでも まあいい心さえあれば
まあその時はまあ 梵天に生まれるんだ
他のは生命はまあそういうなんとかなんとかという地獄次元に生きるんだと
で 大体そんな似てる話は宗教にあるんですね
最後の審判で天国か地獄かというものだと
それはもうほとんど予知的な話で
仏教の話はそういうもう明日明後日起こるものでもなくないし
これ宇宙的な次元で宇宙破壊の時のことであって
私たちには何の関係もない話なんです
で それでホッとすることはできるかというと
やっぱりホッとすることはできないんですね
そこでまた心がまた波打ってるんだから
どんどんどんどんその心の波によってまた宇宙が現れ始めるんです
現れ始めて 一応次元近い次元がどんどん現れ始めると
あのただフリーパスで行った人々が
どんどんどんどん下へ下へ下へ来るんです
ですから 物質の現れと同時に
もう生命の現れがあるという話になっちゃうんですね
それでなぜ物質が現れるかというと
その生命がやっぱり物質が欲しがっちゃう
欲しがっちゃうんです
何かなければ困ると その原因がいまだに我々持ってるんです
なんで人間武器を作ってますかというと
人間の心でもうすごい怒りがあるんですね
怒りと恐怖感 我々の輪廻の生き方というのは
いつでもやられっぱなしで殺されっぱなしで
今生きていたっても 人に殺されなくたっても
自然的に我々殺されるでしょうに
ご飯食べても何食べても
それはまた毒であっても食わせちゃうし
いつか死んでしまうちゃう
だからこの嫌な思いしかもう何もないんです
どこに生まれても ものすごい限りなく戦いを競争して生き延びなくちゃいけない
それでもやられちゃうんですね
確実に ですから 我々の心の中ですごい恐怖感と死にたくないんだけど死ぬんだから
その不満感と また他の人にやられてやられる
そういうそういういろんなものを決められてるんですよ
これずっと輪廻の中 ですから
怒りと恐怖感っていうのはいつでもある
その怒りと恐怖感というのは心のエネルギーでしょ
ですから 心の中で落ち着きがないんです
落ち着きがないんだから
何か作っちゃう 何か作る人間作るものは 2種類しかないんです
自分を守るためと 他を殺すために
この科学の世界もすごい科学万能やと色々言ってますけど
仏教から見ればあんた方は 2種類しか作ってない
一つは自分を守るために
もう一つは人を殺すために
それやれなきゃなんとなく不安なんですね
例えば家を作らなくちゃとか
あれしなくちゃ これしなくちゃ